I don't know why Akash has this
animosity towards Drake
[Laughter]
I understand a lot he's a lot of
people's greatest ever and I can't argue
with it but I don't like him objectively
he's great I'm not a fan but I give him
credit objectively he's great he just
doesn't grab okay let's have this here
right here why do you hate Drake because
you're talking to someone who loves
Drake here I love Drake I Don't Love
Drake because I like living vicariously
through rappers and for me Drake was
never somebody that was like oh I want
to do like DMX or somebody's like I can
never live this life in a million
lifetime you know that you can be like
emotionally connected to someone
but being DMX heartbroken is my year one
through Thirty One you know what I mean
what this is not new to me excellent
argument that DMX is like whoa this
guy's talking about [__] that I've never
been exposed to I could see a whole new
world through this DMX is like the wire
on record for me the wire on wax that's
a fire argument that's my actual feeling
and Drake I was always like I just I
don't yeah when you say the thug [__] I
don't buy it when you say the
heartbroken [__] it's like buddy I'll go
listen to an r b album and cry myself to
sleep whatever however I should do it
it's almost too relatable yeah I I you
know okay good okay I'm not buying it I
thought this was a good argument
first of all you haven't been through
with Drake the type of heartbreak Drake
is talking about you haven't experience
you don't yeah you don't know how big of
a sucker I am no it's not it's not the
sucking [__] because he's also talking
about being like a rich popping [__]
and like trying to deal with the These
Hoes and with what's going on and like
all this take a look you haven't been
dealing with that from one to like
whatever years you said like no
absolutely not and I'm like
when Drake was talking that way you were
wearing sneakers that cost hundreds of
dollars no no that's my point yeah yeah
so at that point in your life you're you
don't have Drake experiences at all but
that wasn't romantic to me in the way
that like thug [__] was romantic it was
like oh that's I'm I'm heartbroken all
the time that's whether you're a level
of dealing with fame or whatever these
are problems that aren't as like uh
fantastic I guess is like like fantasy
type yeah it's like oh this
[__] in the streets doing dirt
well I guess
the the hard time difference is like I'm
a real [__] and not a lame so I already
knew them type [__] who do dirt in the
streets and live like that's not
vicarious to me agreed I'm a lame that's
not vicarious number of kids like
exactly not a lame I didn't mean like a
lame I'm high yeah but like like yeah
you know what I'm saying like I I was
that was mean I think we didn't do that
yeah you know what I kind of liked it so
let's like it
the meaner the better this is kind of
fun yeah I don't like therapy Sams
bro yeah some birds the birds yeah
you can't even say suburbs it's a Barbie
kid like I I grew up around exhausted
yeah I did not know I know them and it
was whatever so it didn't seem that
vicarious but that life is too familiar
for you yeah we're a Drake I'm like this
nigga's turnt like he just this is cool
like and Drake is a suburb kid who kind
of plays ad hood [__] and I'm like well
that's a lot of kids I know you know
what I mean yeah so it might just be the
closeness of the and that doesn't I'm
truly not saying he's not incredibly
talented incredibly smart incredibly
charismatic but for me it's like I know
less talented charismatic smart versions
of you already